well the head of Germany's digital
association become joins us now you're
welcome bula to talk about just that
what are our job prospects going to be
in this brave new world are we all going
to become programmers well we have to be
become more programmers for sure but in
indeed the way we work and we will work
will change and the jobs we know now
will change as well and there are big
chances and also big risk and we have to
prepare for it ok so which jobs are
going which jobs are coming do you think
well just to give you an example
somebody who drives the truck at the
moment and bringing stuff from point 1 2
to another in times of autonomous
driving you don't need anybody anymore
who has to drive a truck other jobs like
jobs with digital competences IT
software developer they will increase
and it will be a lot of people a lot of
companies who will look for them so
we're going to have to be a step ahead
this whole time that means education is
going to play a big role how much of a
role is are playing at the moment how
far is Germany coming along well
education will be a key point it's an
education to prepare for the digital age
to have digital competences if one of
the key facts to have a job in the
future and Germany is in the middle
field and it's not enough for the fifth
biggest economy in the world we have to
get in the top rankings and we are not
at the moment how does it do that I mean
how do you work out exactly what to
offer for for something that's changing
so quickly right now yeah what you have
your company has to change software was
something that enables your business and
now it's becoming part of your business
plan is becoming part of a business
business models and that means
digitalization has to be an issue for
the boss and you have to change your
company to get in time ok so it has to
be part and parcel of the business model
what sort of business strategy would you
then advise your clients and the people
you talk to in adopting well you first
have to check where our new companies
coming in your market it's not the
classical
you know company that's in your business
there are new tech companies coming into
running business and you have to check
the market you have to develop new
business models and you have to invest
in software and competences to get new
business models and if you doubt it a
case of disrupt or die I take us back to
the case of the horse and carriage
moving over to the car what would happen
back then well the top 100 horse and
carriage companies as the the the
changing from haas courage to cars came
there was just only one of the top 100
horse encourage companies was just one
left after the cars but it was a german
company was a german company one Jew and
owned company but it closed just ten
years ago so changing a mobility as does
not mean that the company's stay so you
have to change your company and I guess
logistics is something that's really
changing as far as 3d printing for
example goes for example 3d printing
will change the way logistic strategy is
going at the moment you are trying to
you know produce and one area of the
world and trying to transport it to the
another area in times of 3d printing you
just send the data and you just print
your product out at home so governments
should be concentrating on education
companies on their strategy what about
consumers what about people and work is
what should we be concentrating on well
you have to have digital competences and
it's the same thing about education if
you are on the jobs to train your
digital competences if you are you know
dealing with a digital devices and you
make yourself fit in the digital age and
it's very important for your own for
your private life but also for your
business life I guess a good way of
practicing is playing the odd online
game or two every now and then for
example yokas Buddha thank you very much
for coming